and I am Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle thank you for being with us
tonight globalists are on the Run that's
the focus of tonight's angle
they told us it would be wonderful
I believe we can make our economy even
stronger
and make open trade an even greater
force for peace and prosperity in the
new century keeping America competitive
requires us to open more markets for all
I believe the process of globalization
is here to stay there are enormous
benefits to be gained from that Global
integration
and they trashed the populist opposition
Donald Trump is a populist and populism
can be a very dangerous tool if they
look to ride the anger not provide the
answer and that's the problem the larger
problem is a populist racist
know-nothing movement
fundamentally
increases
but that was all wishful thinking from
supply chain nightmares to food and fuel
shortages to pointless Wars massive
Refugee crises the wheels are slowly
coming off the globalization train
now the media hate to report on this but
one of the big stories playing out over
the summer is the rise of the Freedom
Movement
I'm talking about normal people around
the world who are pushing back on the
globalist agenda that's essentially
dominated our politics since the 1990s
now too often we're told that it's
Americans they're the only ones who have
concerns about globalization and what it
means for our culture and our economy
and our way of life
but around the world working people are
now pushing back against a system that
is making a small sliver of the
population very rich while harming the
interests of the vast majority
so if I told you for example that
farmers who are Furious about high costs
and regulations were marching against
government climate fanatics I don't know
you probably think it was happening
somewhere in Rural America but as we
reported last night it's happening in
the Netherlands
the farmers want a stable future
a normal stable future they buy the farm
and they are gone you told me earlier
that they uh they have no future and
they were hanging themselves is that
something that people are aware of is
that a crisis right now uh uh yes this
is a crisis yes
the attack on Farming and agriculture is
terrifying and it's all according to the
globalist Playbook
and in France voters rejected Emmanuel
macron's globalist agenda by giving more
power to left-wing and right-wing
parties
macron's support for the war in Ukraine
was cited repeatedly by both opposition
candidates
They seized on record level inflation to
portray macrona as a leader who paid
more attention to his role on the
Diplomatic stage than to voters
struggling to make ends meet
and in Germany with a globalist green
agenda has basically was once front and
center for the world to see they've
essentially had to admit well whole
thing's a failure
putting the entire country into a
self-inflicted energy crisis so what are
they doing now they're moving back to
well they're bringing back coal
and in Britain Boris Johnson who became
you know he came to power because he was
one of the few politicians who would
Implement brexit globalist hated brexit
he ended up getting distracted by
globalist concerns as well and he
presented himself as someone who is
going to focus on the Working Class
People but then he became enamored by
China and the war in Ukraine
very very important that we understand
that China is a is a a great country
it's going to be a gigantic fact of uh
the world's economy for a long time to
come and let me say no to the people of
Ukraine that I know that we in the UK
will continue to back your fight for
freedom for as long as it takes the
globalists routinely argue that anyone
who questions the idea of open markets
and open borders that they're
destabilizing the global system but the
truth is it's globalization itself that
is destabilizing and weakening Great
Western Nations that have existed for
centuries
and let's be real almost all of us at
this point know who the real winner in
the globalization game is
of course he aggressively defends the
system against any and all critics
it is true that economic globalization
has created new problems
but this is no justification to write
off economic globalization altogether
rather we should adapt to and guide
economic globalization well ironically
of course gee he's the best you know
biggest nationalist of all threatening
anyone or any country that gets in his
way as China did recently with Australia
when its Air Force was merely conducting
routine missions over international
waters
and of course when push comes to shove
on almost every issue the political
business and media establishment here
they agree with the CCP I think pretty
much every step of the way actually they
don't just agree with them they end up
rewarding China we have a shocking
development on that front involving
Hunter Biden we're going to bring you in
just a few moments
now in the globalist worldview it's
totally logical for them to criticize
and punish States here like Florida and
Mississippi when according to the elites
they're not living up to the modern
Norms you know abortion trans rights Etc
but nothing that happens inside China
matters to the globalists not the
uyghurs being tortured not dissidents
imprisoned not child labor abuses not
Hong Kong and their freedom being
smashed certainly not the coveted
lockdowns welding people into their
Apartments they don't care about any of
that
High Flyers in business and politics
just signed a letter
urging President Biden to seek more
cooperation and accommodation with China
well of course none of them have to
worry about getting their jobs offshore
to China or having their neighborhoods
flooded with fentanyl wow they have to
worry about that
but courtesy of globalization China has
the power the money and the prestige to
bully the United States when it's being
run by an incompetent corrupt Bunch like
the Biden Administration
and their answer to that well the white
Administration basically is saying thank
you sir may I have another
Biden's close to lifting Trump's tariffs
on Chinese Goods
and Janet yellen's meeting with her
counterpart and blinking with his this
week nothing good is going to come out
of that
and by the way goofball John Kerry he
still thinks China is going to be a key
Ally in fighting climate change this is
hilarious of course China's just moving
full steam ahead with coal and its own
refining capacity building that up huge
so things are so bad America's so
weakened a state department official
actually is quoted today as saying that
America should essentially abandon Asia
to China
that it's dangerous for Washington to
deter a Chinese attack on Taiwan we need
to be investing more in economic
engagement and countering climate change
which will require cooperation with
China
yeah who cares about Taiwan that whole
Taiwan things overrated let's just keep
pouring billions of dollars into Ukraine
forever
look we're gonna win this debate we're
already winning this debate and in 2024
the American people will want to know
that Above All Else
the American president this time as he
was in 2016 and his whole cabinet will
put our interests first
Biden and his team clearly don't and
won't and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else